so my point is we have all these
positive reinforcements for women doing
something that is very addictive to us
and hurts our ability to stay with the
husband long term we have an older corn
star Adriana chechik talking about what
dating is like in her position now she
is known for I guess doing a lot of
crazy stuff online some wild scenes and
she talks about it here what that has
led to for her in the dating Market
I find it incredibly hard to date to the
point where I actually like can't can't
dates so there's two perspectives on
that so if I were to go meet somebody
it's kind of hard because I don't like
random people to know my real name so
obviously I'm meeting them as Adriana
chechik and that's extremely hard it's
intimidating I've had guys literally
walk out on me when I've met them